I love this man so does my wife as she
worked with him working college football
for many years way back on ABC when ABC
Sports did all that he's now the face
and voice of so many events for our
friends at NBC and his show lunch talk
live has been preceding ours for the
last two months I love this man I don't
care who knows it his name's Mike Tirico
how are you Mike I I feel the same for
you rich even though you've run me out
of the neighborhood your show is too big
because I'm seeing blocks move along
move along to another block where I
could dominate you know what Mike I just
love watching you do your thing I've
enjoyed seeing your your home office
your reflect you know we all flex with
our home offices when we show them off
you know did you say you had a rewsey oh
nice stick is that what you told missed
one time that's what's behind Mike
Eruzione Mike Eruzione autographed stick
it's a wooden stick Canadian brand and a
bunch of the hockey guys who I know like
that is really really old-school and as
I guess it is but I don't have many
autographs I think I may have bought
that in all two nor one as I should say
in an auction so have you had do we know
do we yeah you have you had it
authenticated do we know that that's
it's not like Mike Eruzione you know
like you know yeah there is Ian actually
a participe
it could be you know could be my garlic
lowered eyes like that I don't know but
you know what if it's mark Eruzione
stick who cares
it's funny man you sent a text to me and
and my wife a few weeks ago about you
watching a replay of that Michigan
Michigan State triple overtime game that
you were doing play-by-play she was
doing sidelines of where I was actually
at the game in person and fearful of her
life because if Michigan fans stormed
the field I thought I'd never see her
again but what have you seen of in this
quarantine where everybody's running
back
that you saw that you called that you
either forgot you called or youyou sat
back oh okay like this is something that
I'm I'm glad I was part of over the last
few weeks
well the fun stretch that was in a
stretch when when I texted you all in
that game was on that was a stretch
there was just one run of about I think
10 nights or so yeah that things that I
did on ESPN or ABC reared in different
places always so every night like 9:30 I
get this text a random person hey watch
watching this game hey I remember this
game which was what I think I think I've
seen six or seven Monday Night Football
games
we're here though I thought I may do as
many in Monday Night Football games this
year is anybody else but the one the one
that I did actually sit and watch one
more time was the return to Katrina New
Orleans game back in 2006
unbeliev 53 weeks after Hurricane
Katrina or 55 weeks the game was that
was our third Monday Night Football game
at ESPN so that was Game three in that
run for me and it was I was doing
play-by-play Joe Theismann and Tony
Kornheiser and I kind of watched the
game afraid of watching it now 14 years
later because hopefully you get better
at what you do 14 years after the fact
and I'm thinking oh my god I must have
been terrible here and the game was so
enjoyable to watch I thought Tony was
just the perfect person to have there
that night and the whole deal
soup-to-nuts and the Steve Gleason block
punt to the first game in the dome for
Drew Brees and Shaun pate as a head
coach quarterback combo to everything I
was surrounded with u2 and Green Day
doing a concert before the game it was a
cool experience and that was the one
that I went back to Washington I just
sat and absorbed the whole game and
really look back in it with great pride
very little to do with you know me
calling third and five or whatever but
when everybody else did on the show
clean Jay Rothman and chip Dean who were
my producer director for my 10 years of
Monday Night Football on our great
friends and our awesome - what they do
that was great memories for me and it
was
nice part of looking back at all these
encore broadcasts well I I was there
that night with NFL Network we brought
the NFL Network through there and and
did pregame and postgame there because
it was such an important night
the Commissioner Paul Tagliabue was
there and as we all know he insisted
that New Orleans not be abandoned and I
think that will be discussed at length
when when the Commissioner does get
inducted into the Hall of Fame when when
that happens but I remember I was
sitting next to Marshall Faulk a native
son of that great city watching the the
coin toss and everyone kind of
disappointed that the Saints had to
start on defense right that was a big
thing like okay let's we want to see
Drew Brees here we go okay let's start
on defense and then on the second down I
think Vick fumbles the ball balls loose
on the ground and the place went crazy
but it rolled out about right and the
number of things that could have gone
differently coin toss bald and roll out
of bounds actually rolled to a saint
that that didn't happen but it led to
Steve Gleason block in that punt which
is now a statue in front of that Stadium
how things work out right you know it
was incredible I remember obviously you
want to get the game going you don't
want to step on stuff there's so much
other stuff going on but it was one of
those games where they open your
microphone to the public address so you
are the PA announcer huh to introduce
the national anthem and I remember
President Bush 41 was doing the
ceremonial coin toss and there was a
brief moment that I do vividly remember
go oh my gosh I'm gonna introduce the
president screw this up whatever you do
say George Bush slowly don't screw this
up and then they cascade of events and
that's what the reads that watched the
game back rich a lot of the game after
the gleason punt block was a blur to me
because of all the build-up but
everything's going in you wanted to nail
the on camera that started the game and
all that stuff so it was fun you know
that night rich I've talked about that
a little bit the last couple of weeks
we've been asked a lot about why Sports
has become a significant part of the
conversation post protest here or as the
protests have been going on and I always
was of the opinion that sports had more
of a meaning than three minutes at the
end of the local newscast or Section C
of the newspaper and maybe we were
trying to justify our existence but that
night I refer to all the time when I
speak about sports because that night
reminded me that Sports has such a civic
pride that almost nothing else carries
that night in the Superdome there were
white and black and there were female
and male and every religion you could
imagine there people who were this great
big bully abased as great big knew this
great big collection of people who would
identify themselves differently on a
census box they were all we're in New
Orleans fleur-de-lis there were in st.
stuff and they were all there to
celebrate and that event showed the
world New Orleans was ready to be open
for business again more than any event
and the orchestra or the ballet they
don't run around with New Orleans across
their tuxedo or the blouse that they're
wearing
but football players and basketball
players do and they represent civic
pride in the community and that night
forever cemented to me
damn I'm gonna I'm going to be very
defensive about what sports is meaning
sports meaning is in our world and I was
glad I had that experience firsthand
because I believe in it passionately I
think we're seeing it with the actions
from athletes and leagues and teams
around the country and around the world
right now well said Mike you're here no
doubt about it Mike Tirico here in the
Rich Eisen show and just hearing what
you had to say about you know
introducing the president you know
Stuart Scott and I were asked by George
Bush's White House to do the
play-by-play of t-ball there used to
hold t-ball games on on the South Lawn
of the White House and our assignment
however was for late September in 2001
and obviously with 9/11 hitting that got
canceled and when it came time to do it
again though
about a year later Stewart couldn't do
it so I went and I I was there I've said
I'm I'm in and they walked me through
the the run of show and they're like so
here's a bunch of cards for you to read
and here's the first card for you to
read as soon as you see the president
and and the first lady walk walked down
read this card make sure you read it
word for word and I looked down it it's
like ladies and gentlemen please welcome
the president the United States and mrs.
Laura Bush and I thought to myself
that's that's okay that's a piece of
cake what else you got for me and I
start looking else in the run a show and
it's time now you stand up and they play
hail to the chief and then you look up
and you see the president the first lady
walking down I'm like it's amazing how
your mind can process something big is
going to happen you don't want to screw
up it's like anybody plays golf okay
do you see the 40 yards of fairway to
the right what do you see the pond to
the left
don't hit it there don't put into the
water that that brings that oh my god
I'm gonna make a massive mistake so yeah
I know know what you received actually
feeling then those are those the good
times oh yeah and another story to tell
you about I know you'll enjoy because I
know your your great friends with Fowler
so so the other night Michigan in
Colorado 1994 is being replayed on ESPN
okay and so I'm catching that now I'm
like you know my son nine-year-old comes
in room Todd hits Michigan football Mike
well first of all so 1994 and plus this
does not end well because so we're not
gonna watch it I'm like well watch it up
to a point you know so so but I'm seeing
Fowler is zooming in from from from his
home and doing some pre taped interviews
I think with Tyrone Wheatley and with
with with the more my playing at
quarterbacks name my gosh with with so
anyway so he's doing these interviews
and whatever
I text him and I'm like you know guess
what's on ESPN right now that I'm
watching and he's like what and I'm like
you know Michigan's got the ball with
five minutes left in a 12-point lead and
he writes back oh yeah that's what's on
right now okay he goes I think the lead
safe what are the chances question mark
[Laughter]
said I'm like where did he go to school
you know I totally forgot right
oh my god that's that that's the
reminder of what makes a sporting event
special and we've had a lot of you go
back and you watch the encore
presentation and you still want to see
it even though you know exactly the way
it ends it's like a good movie I want to
relive it again it I watched last
Saturday because I've done a lot of the
leads and tags for our NBC racing folks
I wasn't working the event right but
when American Pharoah won the Belmont
Tom Hammond who was just so great
covering the Triple Crown races and
covered so much horse racing has a
degree in her in equine science I said
no no mom said that was the loudest he
had ever heard a sporting event he's
done Olympics and all those events and
to watch that a few minutes after
Pharoah wins the Belmont because it was
37 year wait is Larry comas the track
announcer called the race announcer
called on that moment just to watch it
again I'm sitting there going I know
he's gonna win and I'm gonna still watch
this it was just so much fun though that
has been a little bit of a reminder of
what we're missing it we were just
talking about this rich on a conference
call with our production team this week
because we're gonna do the Belmont
Stakes next week yep and there'll be no
fans but the Belmont will run and you're
at the 150 second one five two Belmont
Stakes we're thinking you know what this
is the first American classic sporting
event that will be held arguably since
the NBA all-star game it's been great to
have golf back obviously and it's great
their masks are back the NASCAR didn't
run Desura in Daytona since we're back
golf is playing its first event since
the players was shorted never finished
we haven't had a major all the sports of
the contract
but the American classics the tentpoles
that kind of define our sports history
year after year the last one was
arguably the NBA all-star game maybe if
you don't want to say that you go to the
Super Bowl before that and we've nothing
of that ilk or regard until you get to
the Belmont Stakes which is still
although out of water or triple
cranberries so it kind of next week I'm
getting really excited as we in the talk
show to kind of get ready for getting
back to what I love this job for and
that's these huge events that you talk
about for years and years and years well
you're the best at it man and I
appreciate everything that you do and
everything that you have done and and
and following you on NBCSN the last
couple of months has been a treat
totally has been brother you know how I
feel about you Michael it's fun to elbow
with the Sun up which is really pretty
cool so that's why I love the show keep
it going I have a great appreciation for
what you guys do every day you Dan
Patrick and everybody man it's it's hard
to do one of these shows every day for
three hours let alone for one hour let
alone three so keep on doing and I look
forward to watching you and keep
crushing it all right back at you Mike
you take care yourself that is a that's
it that's the one and only Mike Tirico
hey Mike hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here